[Music]
these are very busy little matchmakers
wingman in every sense of the word you
see the bees side of the hole birds and
the bees business is to help plants find
mates and reproduce in their work as
pollinators honeybees are integral to
the production of nearly 1/3 of the food
that we eat and these bees dutifully
helping lonely plants have sex aren't
alone but rather are part of a very
complex network of matchmaking creatures
critical for the pollination of natural
ecosystems and crops plants in many
natural ecosystems need help to have sex
like many of us they're too busy to find
a relationship they have too much
photosynthesis to do and they can't find
the time to evolve feet and walk to a
singles bar those places are called meat
markets for a reason because plants
can't walk so they need matchmaker
pollinators to transport their pollen
grains to flowers of the same plant
species and they pay these pollinators
with food today around a hundred and
seventy thousand plant species receive
pollination services for more than two
hundred thousand pollinator species
pollinators include many species of bees
butterflies moths flies wasps beetles
even birds and bats who together help
pollinate many species of trees shrubs
and other flowering plants in return
flowering plants are an abundant and
diverse food source for pollinators for
instance fossil records suggest bees may
have evolved from wasps that gave up
hunting after they acquired a taste for
nectar plant pollinator networks are
everywhere ecologists record these
networks in the field by observing which
pollinators visit which plants or by
analyzing the identity of pollen loads
on their bodies networks registered in
these ways contain from twenty to eight
hundred species
these networks show a repeated structure
or architecture pollinators interact
with plants in a very heterogeneous way
most plants are specialists they have
only one or a few matchmakers meanwhile
only a few generalist plants hire a
diverse team of matchmakers getting
visits from almost all the pollinators
of the network the same occurs with
pollinators most are specialists that
feed on only a few plant species while a
few pollinators including the honeybee
usually are generalists busily feeding
from and matchmaking for almost all the
plant species in that ecosystem what's
interesting is that specialists and
generalists across both plants and
pollinators sort themselves out in a
particular pattern most pollinator
networks for which we have data are
nested in a nested Network specialists
tend to interact more with generalists
than with other specialists this is
because if you're a specialist plant and
you're only matchmaker also specializes
on you as it's only food source you're
each more vulnerable to extinction
so you're better off specializing on a
generalist pollinator that has other
sources of food to ensure its
persistence in bad years the same goes
if you're a specialist pollinator you're
better off in the long run specializing
on a generalist plant that gets
pollinated by other species in times
when you're not around to help finally
in addition to nested miss the networks
are usually modular this means that the
species in a network are
compartmentalized into modules of plants
and animals that interact more with each
other than with species in other modules
think of them like social cliques a
plant or pollinator dying off will
affect the species in its module but
those effects will be less severe on the
rest of the network why is all that
important because plant pollinator
network structure affects the stability
of ecosystems heterogeneous distribution
nested nests and modularity enable
networks to better prevent and respond
to extinctions that's critical because
nature is never static some species may
not show up every year plants flower at
different times pollinators mature on
varying schedules generalist pollinators
have to adapt their preferences
depending on whose flowering when so
from one flowering season to the next
the participants and patterns of
matchmaking can drastically change with
all those variables you can understand
the importance of generalist pollinators
like bees to the stability of not only a
crop harvest but the entire network of
plants and pollinators we see in nature
and rely on for life next time you see a
bee fly by remember that it belongs to a
complex network of matchmakers critical
to the love lives of plants all around
you